some new details this afternoon in a
disturbing case that you first saw here
on 8 news now a former actor now accused
of being a cult leader and sexually
abusing girls this is a mug shot we have
now for Nathan Lee chasing horse from
Metro Police law enforcement say he
assaulted young indigenous girls for two
decades in several States he's also
accused of sex trafficking chasing horse
was taken into custody yesterday his
North Las Vegas home raided sources say
chasing horse plan to tell his victims
to take suicide pills before engaging in
a shootout with police which didn't end
up happening police say though this all
started with a tip back in October so
far at least six victims have come
forward we'll have a lot more on the
story later this evening on 8 News Now